cloverworks also adapt um promised
nevertheless
season two they've been on a not a great
streak
really yeah unfortunately which is so
which is such a shame because like they
always start off
so strong right like promise neverland
started off really strong
wonder eggs started off really strong
and just none of them about like
the land everyone's gonna anytime they
get anything now that's going good
everyone's gonna be like guys
go get excited yeah yeah yeah excited
wait just wait just wait just wait just
like
wait until the ending happens yeah
because i was so disappointed when i
heard that because i was actually
um i watched up to episode 10 and i
really really was enjoying it but then i
i remember thinking
and they got still setting up plot
points and still exploring characters 10
episodes in
yeah it's a it's got to end in three
episodes that's not a lot of times yeah
it definitely was built i feel for a 24
episode like a two-core series
but i feel like they just weren't given
the opportunity to i just
also can't believe what they did to
promise neverland season two so if you
don't know promise neverland was an
amazing show absolutely one of the
best-selling manga right
yeah in the top five four right four
four more than mikey academy yeah it's
like the fourth
top five best selling moment of all time
the first season was amazing if you
haven't watched the mung is fantastic
and then instead of just like doing what
they were doing
they're like now hold on guys what if we
just do something else
literally like all right so we're we
just finished the current arc
uh how many chapters do we have left
like 150 how many episodes we have left
three all right skip about 120 episodes
and just go straight to the end
yeah that's that's literally what they
did they [ __ ] the show up completely
and then the final episode was literally
a powerpoint presentation
and and you know how it is you know
there's like when you get a bad
adaptation there's a cool down period
where i it's there's not a set rule but
it's it's like a societal
rule well you you can't make a remake
now within the next ten years yeah
that's ten years now we're not going to
get a good promise neverland
adaptation until someone is like wow
dust this off yeah look at this
i mean they tried they tried to recover
with the live action but that was also
horrible it was a live action it was uh
it was korean though right no it was
japanese yeah i saw the poster it looked
like a [ __ ] porno film like
the i don't know why i think most
live-action anime
adaptations do look like a porno i think
i think it's
actually kind of like japanese sometimes
like movie posters
also look like japanese porn posters
yeah it's
the same production yeah they literally
it's really bizarre
yeah i've seen like strange cosplay
shoots that look better than some of
these posters you know
like it's it's wild seeing like just
how they look sometimes like i remember
the full metal alchemist
like live one and i still haven't seen
that movie
and i [ __ ] refuse to because i saw
the trailer i'm like
this is like if someone with like like
500 subs
uploaded this as like uh as like an
april fool's
parody movie i would believe it like it
was that bad the costumes were
horrible looking like it like [ __ ] it
would look like a crack at it like with
his like hair it's just like
all over the place i'm like no don't do
this why would you massacre my boy like
that
it looks so bad oh
god i just can't get over how they all
look like porn videos
they actually did ask like i've seen
some like
porn like parodies of anime that look
better than some live action anime